à
derniers préparatifs à quelques heures
de la joute
le défi c'est un peu de seconde de
formuler une question qui va permettre
un échange vif
le grand débat le premier en français
réunira tous les chefs et sera diffusée
d'un bout à l'autre du pays
beaucoup beaucoup de gens ne
s'intéressent aux zones se focalise sur
l'élection qu'au moment des débats et
donc pour les candidats extrêmement
important à ce moment de se mettre à la
je pense que je vais continuer à
surprendre les gens le chef libéral est
confiant et se permet même une pause
entre les séances de préparation mais
justin trudeau mise beaucoup sur le
débat énormément de gens à travers le
pays vont effectivement écouter ce débat
ils vont voir à quel point le parti
libéral c'est le seul parti avec un vrai
plan c'est justin trudeau pense à
l'impact national le chef conservateur
lui espère séduire les québécois je
pense pour les québécois comme les
autres canadiens les l'enjeu le plus
important c'est l'économie mais il mise
aussi sur la controverse entourant le
port du niqab il polarise les
québécoises visés par cette question
thomas mulcair lance déjà un appel à la
civilité
aujourd'hui je nous invite à embrasser
une vision plus large et plus
rassembleuse pour notre avenir à tous
des objectifs clairs pour chaque partie
ce moment crucial on hamm est des fois
sur avant les débats mais là compte tenu
du moment où ils arrivent ce débat là je
pense vraiment que ça peut faire une
grande différence
ici daniel thibault radio-canada à
montréal